son las 8:29 minutos de la noche en
Bogotá quito y Lima continuamos en
directo América edición nocturna Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
en Moscú concluyó el segundo día de
reunión entre los presidentes de Rusia y
China los líderes advirtieron que es
necesario evitar que la guerra en
Ucrania entre en una fase incontrolable
con armas nucleares lo hicieron una
mayor referencia al plan de paz de
Beijing
por sexto día las calles de Francia
volvieron a hacer escenario de
multitudinarias protestas ciudadanas
contra el plan de reforma al sistema de
pensiones las marchas terminaron en
choques con las fuerzas de seguridad se
espera un pronunciamiento del presidente
Manuel macún este miércoles
continúa la expectativa en Estados
Unidos donde un Jurado de Nueva York
podría imputar cargos contra el
expresidente Donald Trump por supuesto
pagos ilegales a la actriz pornográfica
stormy Daniels la policía espera
manifestaciones en favor de Trump que
asegura ser objeto de una persecución
política tenemos análisis
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio con información de la
guerra en Ucrania en terreno diplomático
mientras el Primer Ministro japonés
estuvo de visita en kiev el presidente
chino continuó en Moscú su segundo día
de reunión con su homólogo ruso Vladimir
Putin las dos potencias regionales
buscaron reforzar públicamente sus lazos
y firmaron varios acuerdos de
cooperación estratégica Gabriel corson
tiene los detalles
el presidente chino y su homólogo
Vladimir Putin reforzaron su Alianza
Este martes en Moscú los dos jefes de
estado firmaron varios acuerdos de
cooperación
espero mantener estrechos contactos con
el presidente Vladimir Putin en todas
las formas posibles en aras de unas
relaciones chino rusas dinámicas y a
largo plazo
frente a las soluciones occidentales
Moscú tuvo que reorientar parte de su
economía hacia su vecino asiático puchin
anunció un acuerdo sobre el proyecto del
gigantesco gasoducto Power cyberiatum
que unirá Siberia con el noroeste de
china
Lo acabamos de discutir es un buen
proyecto el nuevo gasoducto Power
offsiberia tú a través de mongolia casi
todos los parámetros de este acuerdo han
sido confirmados llevará 50.000 millones
de metros cúbicos de gas un suministro
estable de gases de Rusia la guerra en
Ucrania y el plan de paz chino
estuvieron en el eje de las
conversaciones
por supuesto No ignoramos la situación
en torno a Ucrania cre que muchas de las
disposiciones del plan de paz presentado
por china están en consonancia con los
planteamientos rusos y pueden tomarse
como base para un acuerdo Pacífico
cuando en occidente y en kiev estén
dispuestos a ello sin embargo hasta
ahora no vemos tal disposición por su
parte desde el inicio de la guerra
Beijing adoptó una postura de
neutralidad y nunca condenó la invasión
además su plan de paz no contiene
propuestas concretas para poner fin al
conflicto pese a ser aprobada por
decreto y superar dos mociones de
censura el proyecto de ley que reforma
el sistema de pensiones en Francia
todavía no tiene todas las garantías
para que se ha convertido en ley y se ha
puesto en marcha el tribunal
constitucional francés examinara el
proyecto de manera minuciosa lo que
podría demorar su implementación incluso
puede determinarse que sea sometido a un
referendo ciudadano sobre este tema se
espera que el presidente Manuel se
pronuncie el día de mañana
francesa ya ha sobrevivido Por poco a
dos mociones de censura Pero eso no ha
hecho nada Para calmar el tenso
enfrentamiento tanto en el parlamento
como en las calles y ahora qué pasa con
el proyecto de ley de pensiones del
presidente macron lo posiciona aún tiene
opciones para hacer descarrilar la
reforma podría solicitar una revisión
por parte del Consejo constitucional de
Francia este órgano tiene el poder de
modificar los proyectos de ley o
anularlos por completo si los considera
inconstitucionales los líderes
parlamentarios de los grupos de
izquierdas y derechas dentro de la
asamblea nacional ya han dicho que
solicitarán una revisión judicial así
como la primera ministra Elizabeth o
traducción abierta a la oposición es
convocar un referéndum para que se
organice un referéndum es necesario que
al menos una quinta parte de los
legisladores franceses se adhieran a la
propuesta es decir 185 de los 925
senadores y diputados que componen las
cámaras alta y baja del parlamento
francés luego necesitaría el respaldo de
al menos una décima parte de los
votantes con derecho a voto es decir 185
millones de personas que dispondrían de
nueve meses para manifestar su apoyo a
la organización de una votación Incluso
si la legislación de macron supera esos
obstáculos las esperanzas de la
oposición podrían recibir en las
protestas callejeras en 2006 los planes
del gobierno de para introducir un
controvertido contrato de trabajo
juvenil fueron archivados tras semanas
de manifestaciones masivas la lucha no
ha terminado es como lo que pasó con el
contrato de trabajo juvenil mientras no
se aplique la ley Seguiremos luchando
[Música]
los sindicatos ya han convocado una
jornada de paros masivos y protestas
para este juez
vamos a Estados Unidos y continuamos en
la ciudad de Nueva York donde se espera
que una corte de Manhattan se pronuncia
sobre el caso del expresidente Donald
Trump y la actriz pornográfica Astro
milenials el ex mandatario podría ser
imputado por haber pagado presuntamente
a la mujer para que guardara silencio
tras tener relaciones sexuales el fin de
semana Trump pidió a sus seguidores que
protestaran en contra de la decisión que
llevaría a su detención para analizar
esta información conectamos con Ernesto
Castañeda él es analista político y
profesora asociado en el departamento de
sociología de American University
Bienvenido a France 24
si desde fuera de Estados Unidos vemos
los diferentes procesos que enfrenta
Trump este podría no parecer tan grave
pero entonces por qué levanta tanto
revuelo y Qué posibilidades reales hay
de que Trump se ha imputado
muy buenas noches Valentina Así es este
no es uno de los crímenes más grandes
que se le imputan o por los que están
habiendo investigaciones sin embargo es
el primero que Está avanzando y vieron
hoy presentaciones de datos Y que pronto
podemos Escuchar alguna resolución del
Jurado por eso es el primero que se está
discutiendo pero tiene razón no es el
más grave Este es un ejemplo más en el
que Trump usa sus seguidores para tratar
de de salirse con la suya y de tener lo
que él dice es un apoyo de su movimiento
hacia su persona Bueno y qué supondría
para Trump esa imputación y también para
la democracia en Estados Unidos
la democracia no se ve afectada Está
siguiendo las órdenes de la corte y lo
que los tribunales digan él ya ha
comentado que aunque se ha imputado de
estos cargos él seguiría corriendo las
elecciones ese sería siendo un candidato
y por ser un crimen no violento no es
probable que vaya a la cárcel Así que es
una manera gestosa Trump de llamar a sus
seguidores para mostrar su apoyo y un
poquito para amenazar a en este caso al
a la gente Nueva York de que no lo de
que no intente ponerlo este bajo
bajos celda todavía bueno Y aunque
saliera absuelto puede que este caso
afecte su carrera frente a ron de santis
que es un hombre muy conservador en las
primarias del partido republicano
curiosamente lo ha usado muy
inteligentemente Trump para ver quién
está apoyándolo y quién no la base del
partido republicano sigue siendo muy
fiel a Trump y se le estaba presionando
mucho para que de santis hablara en
contra de estos cargos que vienen y ha
conseguido esto Trump entonces de santis
lleva una declaración donde dice que
esto es algo puramente político sin
embargo no hay mucha evidencia en muchos
de los casos contra Trump de que sean
roto vayas varias varias leyes Por lo
cual es un proceso serio pues señor
Castañeda usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en France 24 muchas gracias buenas
noches y el Distrito Escolar unificado
de la ciudad de Los Ángeles en
California dio inicio a tres días de
protestas por parte de los trabajadores
miles de ellos reclaman mejores
condiciones salariales y culpan a los
sindicatos del estancamiento en las
negociaciones la suspensión de
actividades escolares que amenaza con
prolongarse afecta a más de medio millón
de estudiantes
Este martes decenas de miles de
trabajadores del Distrito Escolar
unificado de Los Ángeles iniciaron una
huelga de tres días el motivo el escaso
avance de las negociaciones paritarias
los dos gremios más importantes del
distrito se unieron para reclamar
mejores condiciones laborales y mayor
personal en el segundo sistema escolar
más grande de Estados Unidos
[Aplausos]
estos son los compañeros de trabajo que
son los trabajadores peor pagados en
nuestras escuelas y no podemos quedarnos
de brazos cruzados ya que constantemente
Los vemos irrespetados y maltratados por
este distrito
bajo la lluvia se desarrolló la primera
protesta de trabajadores protagonizada
principalmente por maestros pero que
también incluyó ayudantes consejeros
miembros de educación especial
transportistas y conserjes entre otros
los sindicatos exigen Un aumento al 30%
y alegan que algunos trabajadores de la
comunidad educativa están por debajo de
la línea de la pobreza y luchan contra
la inflación y el alto costo de vida en
Los Ángeles
tenemos que hacerles saber que estamos
aquí por respeto y que no nos vamos a
conformar con nada menos que eso Este es
una huelga de tres días pero puede
convertirse en algo más grande si es
necesario
el sistema educativo de Los Ángeles
alberga a media emisión de estudiantes
locales y engloba la mayor parte de los
jóvenes de 25 ciudades aledañas de los
cuales tres cuartas partes son latinos
en otras noticias el gobierno
ecuatoriano calificó de atentado
terrorista al enviado de dispositivos
USB con explosivos a reconocidos
periodistas del país desde el Ministerio
del interior recordaron que ya hay una
investigación sobre los cinco sobres que
fueron enviados desde la ciudad de
kinsaloma tres hacia Guayaquil y dos
hacia quito según las autoridades en los
cinco casos se trata de la misma
composición la misma estructura y el
mismo dispositivo lo que significa que
todos los artefactos tenían el mismo
objetivo uno de los dispositivos explotó
el lunes cuando el periodista Lenin
artieda del Canal televisivo ecuavisa
intentó abrirlo en un computador del
canal
cambiamos de tema y vamos a África en
uganda el parlamento de ese país aprobó
una ley que indica que los miembros del
colectivo lgtbi más no pueden
identificarse como miembros de esa
minoría de lo contrario se exponen
apenas severas como la cadena perpetua o
la pena de muerte por parte de la
justicia
es un retroceso para los derechos de las
personas
lgtbiq más en uganda este martes el
parlamento aprobó una ley que prohíbe
identificarse como lgtbiqmas esta cámara
no temerá restringir ningún derecho en
la medida en que reconozca proteja y
salvaguarde la soberanía de este país la
moral de este país las culturas bueno
Wanda la homosexualidad ella es ilegal
como en más de 30 países en África pero
es el primero según la organización
en prohibir el mero hecho de
identificarse como lesbiana bisexual
transexual o queer el motivo que dan las
fuerzas conservadoras representa una
amenaza para los valores tradicionales
unidades básica de nuestra sociedad es
la familia si destruyes la familia
destruyes nuestra sociedad
afirmaciones que atentan contra la
dignidad de las personas en un país en
el que los miembros del colectivo ya
sufren a persecución como denuncia a
Eric no adula activista lgtbiq más de 26
años al que echaron de su casa alquilada
después de reconocerlo como homosexual
llegó un individuo que decidió hacer un
video sobre mí y el trabajo que hago
online lo compartió en Facebook y en
cuestión de minutos se hizo viral mi
casero me trajo el video con una orden
de desahucio la mañana siguiente
además de las relaciones entre personas
del mismo sexo la ley prohíbe la
promoción y la conspiración sobre la
homosexualidad y las condenas por
infracción son muy severas desde cadena
perpetua hasta incluso pena de muerte
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega Andrés espinal con toda la
información de nuestra red de
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]